we mentioned the dolphins during that
conversation and during the show we
talked about the decision to sign
running back mark walton fourth round
pick of the bengals in 2018 didn't
contribute much last year not a high-end
talent not like a joe mixon type of a
figure cut by the bengals after three
off-season arrests the dolphins give him
a tryout they signed the 90-man roster
here's what i'm struggling with yeah
look sure
three arrests are three arrests right
and i'd like to think at a certain point
wrong place wrong time goes out the
window you start making sure you're in
the right place all the time and you
never get yourself in a spot where you
can be accused of anything wrong
second chances typically go to guys who
are highly talented the dolphins
apparently see enough in mark walton to
justify a second chance what are we
seeing i mean what's more i mean what's
he done to justify a second chance like
there's plenty of running backs out
there why are you rolling the dice on a
guy who there's no reason to believe
he's going to be a great player and
maybe maybe we're missing something and
i think that's the message the dolphins
must see something the rest of us are
missing because why else would you put
yourself in this position where you're
giving a second chance to a guy that
that is fungible no i think that's
exactly what it is they see a player
here that's uh they probably had their
eye on first of all that's where i make
the first connection you know i do think
you know and again this happens in the
nfl teams have greater awareness and
greater connections with the colleges
that are closer to you know their
prospective cities and the miami
dolphins of course are right down the
road from the university of miami uh i
would think they're very well connected
to that school down there and all the
people that are around the football
program uh with the hurricanes to where
yeah they feel like they know the player
that's probably one reason they're
taking a little bit of a chance here and
just dealing with the bad pr the other
thing is i think they do look at it and
go yeah this guy has a chance to be
starting running back type material he
does i mean hey we talk about it all the
time as a fourth round pick uh he had a
little bit of an underwhelming combine i
think that made him fall to that level
too to where uh i think that hurt him
but hey we saw kareem hunk drafted in
the fourth round a few years ago lead
the nfl in rushing third big club third
okay jordan yeah but then jordan howard
that same year he was second in the
league in russian he was a six-round
pick so yeah well he was a fourth so i'm
all confused in my numbers either way
you got my point there um so yeah
they're taking a flyer on a guy and
i said this during the i listen i'm
never for breaking the law okay
you know but i think some of these
issues and some of the arrests he's had
they maybe feel better that they can
deal with you know uh
what he did wrong to get arrested you
know so
that's where i make the logic of it i
know brian flores i know what kind of
guy he is i don't think he would sign a
guy that's just like a total bad apple
bad person total malice in his eyes and
just done bad bad things i think this
case this is a case where this is a
young a young man who made some immature
mistakes not necessarily mean malice
like trying to scam the world type
mistakes by the way we'll split the
difference on jordan howard he's a fifth
round he was a fifth round okay good
good uh but i was i went four and you
went six so price is right i'd win you
went yeah well no you went you went
under it went over you don't you i win i
kept it under shut up yes
but but again they that must be that's
the takeaway here now that we've talked
it through they see something in mark
walton i think that maybe the rest of us
don't yes and they're expect they
wouldn't be doing this if they didn't
think he's going to make it to the
53-man roster and he's going to
contribute to the team this isn't just
we're going to take a flyer on a guy
who's been arrested three times no i
don't think it is that either and i
think because of the arrest and again
i'm not saying any of them are good i
don't think they're the most egregious
uh things we've ever seen in the world
and especially felony charges for
concealed well and i understand yeah how
many directions that can go understand i
understand that can be abused hey one
thing we're learning from the robert
craft case there's plenty of police
abuse right what is what is concealed
weapon like explain it to me like i mean
did he not have it concealed in the
proper holder no i don't right i don't
is it loose in the back of his car
that's so that's what i mean i don't
take a gun outside of the house so i
don't know what the laws or limits are
on what is and what isn't permissible
gotcha you have it for home defense
under the you know the thing that never
happens but you want to be ready just in
case right but you don't take it out i
would have no reason to take it out of
the house
i'd like to don't rob florio's house he
has a gun okay well everybody i live in
west virginia
i know they do but but no there's no
reason if you need if you i'll look at
it this way and i don't know people are
going to view this as a political
comment if you need to carry a gun out
in public
you should move right move to a place
where you don't feel compelled i
certainly don't in public don't see the
need of it yes all right unless you just
want to come off as a hard-ass cowboy
which i think a lot of the people who
wear who will carry a gun in public just
want to do i've been walking around
the parts of new york city the bronx or
brooklyn and never felt inclined like oh
gosh i gotta have a gun on my hip here
to feel safe so i think that it's an
intimidation device
uh and uh a lot of people do it for that
purpose and that purpose
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports